as the russian advance continues i'm
joined by air marshal edward stringer to
analyze the situation on the ground
thanks for being with us marshall now in
the last few hours we've seen some
extraordinary video being released of
the belarusian president alexander
lukashenko seeming to give away the
entire
invasion plan
yes he seems to be briefing the uh the
the war plan here and what you see with
these four regions that's the four
regional commands that's the command
structure of the ukrainian armed forces
you'd expect to see that on a map they'd
be briefing but interestingly on that
map we do have an area that had some
arrows going towards it and it's this
area here isn't it on the ukrainian
moldova border why is that area of
interest that shows that russian forces
may be moving towards there well we
don't see any activity there at the
moment but on his map you could see
clearly a thrust from the sea up towards
moldova and it looked like they'd
blocked out the entire area of
transnistra that disputed area between
moldova and ukraine
now of course there are a number of
cities that are coming under attack by
uh the russian forces this here shows us
exactly the russian armoured column that
we understand is 40 kilometers long
making its way towards kiev now uh we've
got a satellite image of this column um
many people will be wondering when they
look at a picture like this as you can
see there are trucks arrayed along the
road sometimes three abreast why don't
the ukrainians bomb that
well we don't really know what the state
of the ukrainian air force is at the
moment we don't we don't know what its
reserves of uh um edgar ammunitions are
um
but we can
we must imagine actually that they will
be husbanding that that air force for
more vital operations to protect those
capital cities where where government
currently uh exists now that's the fight
uh for kiev potentially coming in in the
coming days but also there are assaults
occurring around kirsan and mario pole
mariopole being shelled from the sea we
think why are these two cities so
important
they are both very significant uh ports
on the black sea uh sea of azov but
they're also key nodes on that land
corridor just south of the juniper river
that goes up
from crimea links it through donbass
into russia and curse on itself is the
administrative centre of the kursan
oblast the kersen region now in the past
24 hours and for the past few days there
have been many many calls for a
nato enforced no-fly zone across ukraine
to try and stop russian air power is
that going to happen
i suspect not
all the western politicians have been
very keen from the start of this uh
start this war to point out that nato
forces won't be uh won't be deployed on
the ground nato forces in the air are
still nato forces if they're engaging
russian aircraft at that point you do
have a war of nato against russia and
that sort of confrontation as as we all
know it could be the trigger for world
war three and that's something that
nobody wants